[Music]
farmer's daughter take one
i need to be famous wayne
all the best people are ain't nobody
else out there like you
you know what
why
because you got that x factor
that days of struggling may soon be over
hollywood here we go
this is it our own studio background
i'm looking for a place to stay
oh yes sir
that's one of this home [ __ ]
and my wife pearl is next door so i
would appreciate a little discretion
you don't know what we're doing does he
oh it's better to beg for forgiveness
and ask for permission
would you like to
come inside
my surprise
i want to be in the movie well you can't
the story can't just change midway
through
if daddy catches us
there's no telling what he might do
my wife is not well
it happens after darkness
[Music]
you don't want to leave do you people's
eyes are going to pop out of their damn
skulls when i see this
what are you all right
now
[Music]
all the boys found this inside what do
you think is on it
i see one goddamn [ __ ] up horror
picture
[Music]
foreign